[Música]
el partido republicano de Estados Unidos
llegó a la esperada cifra de 218 escaños
lo que les da la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes la cámara baja del
Congreso entre tanto los demócratas
alcanzan 211 representantes el recién
confirmado líder de los republicanos
Kevin mccarthy sucedería a Nancy pelosi
en el tercer cargo de mayor importancia
política del país
con una calurosa bienvenida fue recibido
el presidente electo de Brasil y si
nació Lula da Silva en la conferencia
climática de Naciones Unidas en Egipto
el mandatario se pronunció a favor de
proteger la amazonía señaló que es una
clave que exista se para que exista la
seguridad climática en el planeta
se cumplieron 26 días de paro en la
ciudad boliviana de Santa Cruz donde
tras 72 horas de plazo al gobierno para
liberar a los detenidos durante las
manifestaciones los líderes de la huelga
anunciaron que continuará ampliamos
desde la paz con nuestra corresponsal
24 estamos de vuelta con las noticias
que marcan la jornada soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Estados
Unidos porque los republicanos
consiguieron llegar a los 218 escaños
adjudicados en la cámara de
representantes la anhelada cifra que
garantiza obtener la mayoría de esta
forma los rojos se hacen con la cámara
baja del Congreso donde los demócratas
obtienen por ahora 211 escaños el
recuento de votos de las elecciones de
medio término realizadas el pasado 8 de
noviembre se ha extendido por más de una
semana
este panorama confirma que Kevin
mccarthy es el mejor posicionado para
reemplazar a Nancy pelosi como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes la cámara baja del
Congreso un cargo considerado como el
tercero en importancia política en
Estados Unidos a continuación les
contamos más de su perfil
es un republicano devoto de un Distrito
conservador en medio de un estado
demócrata California Kevin mccarthy de
57 años actual líder de La minoría
republicana tiene todos los números para
convertirse en el nuevo presidente de la
cámara de representantes ha sido su
objetivo desde que llegó a Washington
desde Bakersfield en 2007 como
congresista asumiría el tercer cargo con
más poder político de Estados Unidos por
detrás de la presidencia y la
vicepresidencia
Porque alguien quiere llegar a la
presidencia de la cámara por poder y
ambición
y francamente Kevin mccarthy ha sido
criticado por eso porque significa
abandonar ciertos principios principios
conservadores y republicanos a cambio de
la ambición de ganar
mccarthy casi consigue el martillo en
2015 cuando el republicano John viener
anunció su renuncia pero sus choques con
el Freedom kaucus el grupo
ultraconservador publicano en el
congreso se lo impidieron y el puesto
fue para Paul Ryan por eso recientemente
mccarthy se ha acercado a los miembros
del grupo ultraconservador incluido al
congresista por Ohio Jim Jordan a quien
ayudó a conseguir una codiciada
oposición en el comité judicial de la
cámara mccarthy también fue uno de los
primeros en apoyar a Donald Trump de
hecho vinculó su suerte a la del
expresidente lo que resultó ser un arma
de doble filo y en 2020 se hizo eco de
las acusaciones infundadas de fraude en
las elecciones presidenciales
si me pregunta mi opinión creo que tiene
que verificarse legalmente cada voto
creo que hay que terminar todo lo
reconteos y que el resultado de cada
impugnación debe hacerse público
mccarthy también votó en contra de la
certificación de los resultados
electorales en Arizona y Pensilvania el
6 de enero de 2021 Aunque el republicano
condenó el asalto al Capitolio y
denunció el comportamiento de Donald
Trump semanas después fue amar a lago a
retractarse y a intentar recuperar el
aprecio del hombre que una vez le llamó
mi Kevin Trump todavía mantiene una gran
influencia sobre el partido republicano
y su poder puede dificultar la tarea del
nuevo presidente de la cámara que deberá
hacer equilibrios entre las distintas
facciones republicanas
en la ciudad de Los Ángeles un vehículo
Arroyo acerca de 22 reclutas hiriendo
gravemente a cinco de ellos cuando
realizaban un entrenamiento de rutina el
accidente ocurrió en los urbios de
whittier en donde queda ubicada una
academia de formación militar
el 75 reclutas estaban tratando en una
de las vías cercanas cuando un vehículo
alta velocidad que era conducido en el
carril contrario embistió al grupo de
personas dejando a varios heridos entre
ellos el conductor del vehículo que
colaboró con las autoridades la
investigación apunta a un presunto acto
intencional o conducción bajo efectos
del alcohol
el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio lulada Silva pronunció un
esperado discurso en la con 27 Lula
aseguró que devolverá a su país a la
escena internacional para luchar contra
la crisis ambiental y las desigualdades
en el mundo al mismo tiempo criticó el
gobierno del ultraderechista Yair
bolsonaro en el que según dijo hubo un
enorme retroceso en temas ambientales
entre aplausos y cantos así fue la
recepción del presidente electo de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en la
con 27 el izquierdista pronunció un
discurso en el que dejó algo claro
Brasil está de vuelta en la escena
internacional Un regreso en el que según
Lula se luchará contra el cambio
climático y las desigualdades a nivel
mundial y del que cobrará la deuda
pendiente de los países desarrollados
con los países más vulnerables 100 mil
millones de dólares que aseguró aún no
se han pagado
Los acuerdos Tienen que salir del papel
y para eso es imprescindible volver
disponibles los recursos para que los
más pobres puedan enfrentar las
consecuencias de los problemas creados
en buena medida por los países más ricos
de una manera desproporcionada que está
afectando a los más vulnerables
en la con 27 Lula mostró su voluntad de
desmarcarse de su predecesor ya ir por
sunaru y reactivar los esfuerzos por
luchar contra la deforestación que llegó
a máximos en los últimos 15 años durante
el mandato del ultraderechista
no hay seguridad climática para el mundo
sino una amazonía protegida
el resultado de las elecciones
brasileñas dependía no sólo la paz y el
bienestar del pueblo brasileño sino
también la supervivencia de la amazonía
y por lo tanto la supervivencia de
nuestro planeta
la creación de una cumbre de los países
amazónicos fue uno de los primeros
anuncios a nivel internacional que hizo
Lula desde su elección en octubre al
mismo tiempo esbozó varias líneas que
seguirá durante su mandato
luchar contra los crímenes ambientales y
crear un Ministerio de los pueblos
originarios
vamos a Nicaragua porque el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega cerró otras 91 ongs 27 de
ellas religiosas argumentando que han
incumplido sus obligaciones a no
reportar por periodos de entre 2 y 29
años juntas directivas estados
financieros balanza de comprobación
detalle de donaciones y información de
identidad de origen de todos sus
miembros donantes con esta nueva
clausura masiva el gobierno suma 2.926
organizaciones y legalizadas desde 2018
pero la mayoría de los cierres se han
producido desde marzo pasado
finalizamos en Bolivia se cumplen 26
días de paro en Santa Cruz pasaron la 72
horas que los líderes de la huelga
dieron para que el gobierno liberara a
los manifestantes detenidos entre otras
propuestas y Pese a que hubo avances
ahora anuncian que continuarán con los
bloqueos y manifestaciones previamente
hablamos con Mary vaca corresponsal de
France 24 en la paz que hizo un balance
de estos 26 días de paro se puede decir
que es hasta ahora el paro más largo del
que se tenga memoria en Bolivia y si
bien ha sido un paro que ha sido acatado
y seguido por la mayor parte de la
población del departamento de Santa Cruz
también hay que decir que ha sido una
movilización violenta de ambos lados que
significa eso que los movimientos
sociales que apoyan al presidente Luis
Arce también han tenido su parte en
estos actos de violencia pues ellos han
protagonizado para empezar un cerco en
torno a la ciudad de Santa Cruz para
impedir el ingreso o salida de alimentos
también han hecho un bloqueo en torno la
refinería de Palma sola para evitar que
salga combustible hacia la ciudad y
finalmente han protagonizado marchas de
protesta y una de estas marchas ha
derivado en enfrentamientos durísimos
con los grupos cívicos estos grupos
cívicos por su parte han desplazado a
sus bloqueadores hacia las sedes
sindicales de estos sectores sociales y
han provocado la quema de una de esas
sedes y daños serios en otros puntos y
establecimientos de el presidente Luis
Arce o de grupos que apoyan al
presidente el Luis Arce por otro lado
hay que decir que durante estos 26 días
de paro ya se han producido tres
fallecimientos en diversas
circunstancias en lo que va de la medida
de presión también hay varios heridos
más de una veintena de detenidos y las
pérdidas económicas son cuantiosas según
los cálculos del gobierno hasta la fecha
el país habría perdido cerca de mil
millones de dólares por estas protestas
por su parte el gobierno gobierno de
Luis arce y particularmente el
presidente acusado a los líderes de la
protesta y al gobernador de Santa Cruz
de estar desestabilizando a su gobierno
de estar queriendo hacer un golpe de
estado ellos han rechazado la denuncia
asegurando que lo único que buscan es
que el censo de población y vivienda se
realicen 2023 y no el 2024 como pretende
el gobierno de Luis Arce es todo por el
momento en Francia 24 quédense con
nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]